عمران خان يذوق من نفس الكاس التي طالما
اتهم خصومه بها الامن الباكستاني يعتقل
رئيس الوزراء السابق على خلفيه قضيه فساد
يحقق فيها مكتب المحاسبه الوطني عمران
خانز طبق اعتقاله بتسجيل المصور دعا فيه
انصاره للتظاهر من اجل نيل حقوقهم
اعلم انه سيتم اعتقالي في قضيه ملفقه دون
مراعاه للقانون والحقوق الاساسيه طيله عمل
السياسي كان كفاح سلميا وهذه الحكومه
المستورده والفاسده تريد مني القبول بها
اريد منكم جميعا الخروج من اجل نيل الحريه
الحقيقيه فالحريه لا تمنح وانما تكتسب
بالجد والجهد
الحكومه الباكستانيه جددت اتهامها عمران
خان بالفساد والعمل على اثاره الفوضى في
البلاد
تم اعتقال عمران خان وفق القانون بتهمه
اختلاس اموال من حق الدوله قدرها 190
مليون جنيه استرليني والاستحواذ على مئات
فدانات الاراضي بطريقه غير قانونيه انه
يعمل وفق اجنده خارجيه لزعزعه استقرار
البلاد ويشن حمله منظمه للنيل من مؤسسات
الدوله
اعتقال عمران خان ياتي بعد يوم من بيان
للجيش الباكستاني يحذره فيه من اطلاق
اتهامات غير مسؤوله في اشاره للتهامات
وجهها لضابط بالتامر لقتله
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق نظموا تجمعات
احتجاجيه في عدد من المدن تخللت بعضها
اعمال شغب واقتحام مقرات للجيش وحذروا
الحكومه من المساس بعمران خان فيما قررت
السلطات حضرت في مدن كبرى واستدعت تعزيزات
من قوات الامن
ويواجه رئيس الوزراء السابق لائحه طويله
من القضايا تتعلق باتهامات بالفساد
والارهاب والاخلال بالامن يعتبرها هو
وانصاره مسيزه وماهيه
في ظل الجدل القضائي والسياسي حول القضايا
المرفوعه ضد الرئيس وزراء السابق عمران
خان واعتبار انصاره ان المساس به خط احمر
يحذر مراقبنا من خروج الاوضاع عن السيطره
ودخول البلاد نفقه ازمه جديده في ظل ما
تعانيه من اوضاع امنيه واقتصاديه صعبه عبد
الرحمن زيني العربيه اسلام اباد لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات